[موسيقى]
مخاطر الأداء في ملعب في الهواء الطلق
في شيكاغو ، نحن محظوظون جدًا لأن
لدينا
شيئًا خاطئًا مع تايلور سويفت
إذا قام شخص ما بعمل Heimlich ،
لكن تايلور تمكنت بسرعة من
التخلص من الحشرة بشكل أسرع من
التخلص منها  قصة حب قصيرة مع عازفة البوب ​​الروك
مادي هيلي TMZ وأفاد الناس بأن
الأمر انتهى ، لقد كان الأمر مرتبكًا أكثر
مما كان يشعر بالارتباك بسبب ما حدث في الفتحة
اللذيذة ، وكان
بعض المعجبين يشعرون بالغيرة ، لأننا نجحنا في ابتلاع
تايلور سويفت ، لقد رأينا
المراسلين
والمراسلين يبتلعون الحشرات ويستمرون في ذلك.  مباشرة
عند إرساء حالة طوارئ وطنية تم
استدعاؤها ، رأينا نحلة تتجه إلى
فم
العرض الأول في أونتاريو ، إنها قادمة من القطاع الصحي ،
المسيح المقدس ، لقد ابتلعت للتو الإيقاع على
الأقل حافظت تايلور على لغتها نظيفة
ولم تفعل  حاول أن تصطاد الحشرة بإصبعها
ولم ينتهِ وجهها مبعثرًا
بجثث الحشرات
[موسيقى]
مثلما حافظت تايلور على
أسلوب Poise الذي ينتقد الذات ، فهل
هناك أي فرصة لمعرفة ما إذا كنت قد
رأيت ذلك
لم يره المعجبون فقط  لقد رآه البعض
من وجهة نظر الحشرة ، تخيل أنك
مجرد حشرة تعيش حياتك ، ثم
فجأة أصبحت في معدة تايلور سويفت ،
نعم ، آمل في حدوث ارتداد بسيط في
نيويورك
[تصفيق]